dans un jour cela fait quatorze jours et
14 nuits que les volets du pavillon des
bertrand sont clos ici à
pont-sainte-marie faubourgs de 3 à
l'intérieur la tante l'angoissent de
toute une famille à l'extérieur la
presse la presse utile quand on a besoin
de donner le maximum de publicité au
rapt mais une presse que l'on accuse
aussi de tous les maux à la moindre
bavure
la dernière en date la rançon n'a pas
été récupéré par les ravisseurs
et l'enfant n'a pas été libéré par ce
que dit la famille la presse en a parlé
trop tôt or ni la police ni la justice
n'ont sur ce point demandé à la presse
d'être discrète bien au contraire
sur place des allées et venues du père
et du grand-père de philippe continue
pour eux depuis deux semaines
leur univers c'est la villa de la rue du
docteur roux le palais de justice
l'hôtel de police
l'hôtel de police où depuis 24 heures un
homme est gardé à vue un homme jeunes
appréhendés au volant d'une simca 11/100
rouge sur le parking d'un supermarché de
3 on vérifie son emploi du temps nous a
dit le juge d'instruction bonsoir
la france a peur je crois qu'on peut le
dire aussi nettement la france connaît
la panique depuis qu'hier soir une
vingtaine de minutes après la fin de ce
journal on lui a appris cette horreur
un enfant est mort un 12 enfants au
regard profond assassiné étranglé ou
étouffé on ne sait pas encore le top 6
ne l'a pas complètement révélé par le
monstre qui l'avait enlevée pour de
l'argent la france a peur chaque mère
chaque paire à la gorge nouée quand il
pense à ce qui s'est passé à trois quand
il pense à cet assassin de 23 ans une
relation des parents du petit philippe
un petit commerçant bien me qui a fait
croire jusqu'au bout aux parents que
l'enfant était vivant
un jeune homme apparemment sans passion
qui ne peut pas être autre chose qu'une
sorte de mandat de malade mental mais
qui a pourtant tenu tête avec une froide
lucidité aux policiers qui l'ont
interrogé pendant 48 heures quand il
était le témoin numéro un de la faire
oui la france a peur et nous avons peur
et c'est un sentiment qu'il faut déjà
que nous combattions je crois parce
qu'on voit bien qu'il débouche sur des
envies folles de justice expéditive de
vengeance immédiate et directe
et comme c'est difficile de ne pas céder
à cette tentation quand on imagine la
mort atroce de cet enfant c'est
d'ailleurs probablement pour soustraire
l'assassin à la colère des habitants de
trois qu'on l'a mis en prison dans une
autre ville à chaumont
la france a peur parce que les rapts
d'enfants se sont multipliées d'une
manière épouvantable il y en a eu 7 pour
la seule année 75
mais c'est la première fois depuis 1964
qu'un rapt se termine aussi tragiquement
cette année là lucien léger étrangla le
p'tit luc taron oui la france a peur
parce que comme il y à 12 ans elle ne
comprend pas exactement comme les
parents accablés de patrick henry
l'assassin de philippe en fin de soirée
lorsque nous avons appris que son
véhicule avait été vu
dans la rue de la pension de famille des
chars oui nous avons fait ce de porte à
porte chez tous les chez tous les
commerçants pour présenter la
photographie de ce personnage et c'est
le patron de l'hôtel de charme et qui
nous a dit qu'effectivement
patrick henry avait loué chez lui sous
le nom reprenant d'ailleurs une chambre
depuis le 23 janvier
et nous sommes montés dans ses missions
de nos entendu du bruit
patrick henry était là ils essaient de
fuir dans la terrasse parler de toi mais
les fonctionnaires qui détaille le
commissaire cariven la pj de reims l'ont
arrêté et l'ont amené dans la chambre
vous entendez trouver un roulis le cadre
du mot philippe bertrand est ce que tout
cela permet d'assurer qu'il était seul
cela ne permet pas d'assurer qu'il était
seul le seul l'instruction l enquête
complémentaire
nous continuons à faire dès ce soir ça
vous arrêtez essaiera de le déterminer
je peux vous dire moi personnellement
que je pense qu'ils n'étaient pas
accompagnés
lorsque vous êtes entré dans la chambre
avec la police est ce que vous avez
remarqué quelque chose non
j'ai simplement vu les emballages de sac
le sac de couchage qu'il avait acheté
pour englober l'enfant et moi je suis
ressorti aussitôt de l'argent j'ai
ouvert parce que comme il s'était fermé
d'intérieur j'ai ouvert pour que les
policiers puissent rentrer avec
l'individu en question est ce que ce que
vous connaissez de la chambre de ce que
vous avez vu permet de savoir quand et
où l'enfant est mort mais c'est un avis
tout à fait personnel que je vous donne
mais à mon avis
l'enfant n'a pas été tuée qu'est ce qui
vous fait penser c'est juste au dessus
du bar ont entendu du bruit en a entendu
marché ici on peut accéder à ces
chambres baril ce sans passer par le bar
et c'est au premier étage dans cette
chambre que s'est déroulé l'insoutenable
pendant 19 jours
l'enfant mort sans doute depuis le début
de la fère et patrick henry qui va et
vient dans la ville d'abord témoins et
puis suspect et puis de nouveau libre et
ce soir les soupçons l'arrestation l
écroulement atroce de tous les espoirs
patrick henry a donc loué une chambre
ici une semaine avant le rapt et puis un
jour il est revenu il a suivi ce chemin
avec l'enfant quel jour on ne sait pas
encore les preuves de la culpabilité
sont accablantes
mais pour les circonstances on verra ce
qui est sûr tout a été préparé réfléchi
patrick henry à l'insu du logeur avaient
même changé le verrou de la chambre
comment at il pu qui est patrick henry
quand il est venu vous loué cette
chambre vous l'avez vu vous avez parlé
avec lui oui comment est-il qui est bien
c'est un monsieur qui m'a paru tout à
fait correct c'est un monsieur taille
moyenne blanc je veux dire au point de
vue du caractère apparent du
comportement est ce qu'il a l'air neuf
pas du tout pas du tout vous pensez que
même après le geste qu'il a commis cette
atrocité vous pensez qu'il est fou ou
non d'après ce que vous avez vu de lui
le geste par les ondes on pourrait le
qualifier de folie mais le monsieur
n'est pas fou du tout à mon avis il vous
a paru équilibré tout à fait tout à fait
tout à fait
pour le ministre de l'intérieur michel
poniatowski ce crime est abominable car
tu es un petit enfant il n'y a rien de
pire
j'espère at il dit une préméditation
langue par la sacem et que cette
amélioration comporter
l'exécution de l'enfant
dès le départ
ep très tôt qu'un enfant l'ayant reconnu
connaissez
celui qui révélera et inévitablement le
dénoncer s'il était rendu à ses parents
pour commencer il faut revenir sur le
meurtre du petit philippe bertrand
la colère et l'indignation sont loin
d'avoir disparu à 3 ou demain doivent
avoir lieu les obsèques du jeune garçon
dans sa cellule de la prison de chaumont
patrick henry qui pour l'instant n'est
inculpé que d'enlèvement d'enfants n'a
toujours rien avoué je ne parlerai qu'en
présence de mes avocats avait t-il dit
quand les policiers l'ont arrêté or pour
l'instant aucun avocat ne veut défendre
le meurtrier présumé du petit philippe
par exemple ce soir le bâtonnier bremer
du barreau de l'aube a refusé lui aussi
l'instruction sera accélérée disait hier
monsieur lecanu et accélérait n'est pas
expéditive a ajouté aujourd'hui le
ministre de la justice la justice
précisément c'est elle qui va maintenant
intervenir
c'est elle qui doit nous rappeler que
quel que soit le sentiment que l'on
éprouve dans ce genre d'affaires il faut
que la sérénité pour juger ce qu'il faut
pas que j'existe expéditive et il faut
pas non plus que l'on choisit le genre
d'affaires pour lequel cette justice
s'appliquerait pas ce que c est positif
je ne dirais même pas une justice rapide
car le mot rapide laisserait penser que
il payera justice lente mais une justice
qui s'en tiennent à l'essentiel et qui
dans des délais raisonnables puisse
amener l'inculpé à répondre sans clic
quand on dit que la justice doit passer
rude et vite à votre avis c'est une
erreur il faut qu'elle soit sereine il
faut qu'elle soit sereine
il faut que le soleil peut être eu elle
peut-être
sereine tout l'étang rue de ça c'est une
question d'appréciation je n'aimais pas
la place ce qui ferait surtout c'est que
c'est que tous journalistes citoyens
nous pensions qu'il ya des hommes qui ne
savent même pas que ce sont eux qui sont
choisis dans quelques mois par tirage au
sort pour juger un criminel qui a commis
un crime particulièrement horrible et
bien et c'est ces gens là qui sont parmi
nous que nous pouvons rencontrer demain
dans la rue ou sur les routes
eh bien ces sommes doivent être à l'abri
justement de ce que j'appelais tout à
l'heure cette sorte de matraquage de
l'opinion publique cette mise en
condition de l'opinion publique il faut
que ce soit en toute liberté qui se
prononcer que quelle que soit leur
décision
nous accueillons tous devant la justice
du jury français bonsoir à troyes demain
toute la ville participera aux obsèques
de philippe bertrand qui se dérouleront
à l'église saint bruno et chacun
témoignera ainsi aux parents de philippe
sa compréhension et partagera leur peine
quant à patrick henry pour l'instant il
n'a rien avoué ce qui laisse plusieurs
points dans l'ombre
le juge d'instruction a été déchargé de
tous ses autres dossiers pour ceux que
paie de celui ci conformément à la
procédure d'urgence demandée par
monsieur lecanu est le garde des sceaux
a tenu à préciser que procédure
d'urgence ne voulait pas dire justice
expéditive et il insistait sur leur fait
que la justice doit conserver sa
sérénité
les premiers résultats de l'autopsié
situe la mort du petit garçon à 15 jours
la date précise est un point capital de
l'enquète philippe at il été tué dès le
lendemain du rapt ou bien il y avait une
préméditation dans le premier cas son
acte se situerait après la communication
téléphonique du ravisseur avec le grand
père de la victime
et s'il en était ainsi la fausse
manoeuvre de la gendarmerie serait
regrettable si philippe à ce moment là
était encore en vie l'arrestation de
patrick henry ne sauverait pour les
gendarmes il n'y a pas eu de mauvaise
coordination entre la police et la
gendarmerie
les responsables étaient réunis au
commissariat de police de troyes
il y avait parmi eux comme un groupement
de gendarmerie
à un moment donné il ya eu un flottement
on a craint que les policiers en civil
n'arrive pas à temps pour surveiller au
filet l'individu et le groupement de
gendarmerie a fait ces ombres de service
il a dit je peux envoyer la brigade de
bréviandes qui est tout proche ainsi si
vous le souhaitez le il a eu l'accord 1
du commissaire central et des autres
responsables de l'opération qui se
trouvaient là
il a immédiatement donné ordre par radio
d'aller appréhendé l'individu qui
téléphonent à cet endroit il se trouvait
qu'un véhicule de la gendarmerie
stationnées à quelques centaines de
mètres de cette tribune téléphonique
les gens ils sont allés immédiatement le
plus vite possible mais sans gyrophare
et sans sirène et malheureusement
l'individu les a vus arriver de loin et
a pris la fuite
vous avez vu hier soir un témoignage
presque insupportable de patrick henry
enregistré après un premier
interrogatoire avant qu'on ne découvre
le corps d'enfants de l'enfant dans sa
chambre d'hôtels meublés
mais cela ne suffisait pas pour que cela
soit considéré comme un véritable
portrait de cet homme inquiétant et bien
ce portrait tracé encore à grands traits
grâce aux témoignages de son entourage
et de ses médecins
le voici par jean-louis burgat éducation
normale famille normale activité normale
tout est normal ou presque dans la vie
de patrick henry
jusqu'au 30 janvier 76 et c'est bien ce
qui est terrible naissances au sein
d'une famille de six enfants le père
etienne est vendeur dans un magasin de
sport la mère madeleine travail dans une
blanchisserie normal mais tout de même
pas facile tous les jours avec cinq
frères et soeurs à dison patrie contre
collège saint-pierre cours privés
catholiques fréquenté par la bourgeoisie
de 3 il contemple alors chaque jour des
enfants qui ont beaucoup plus d'argent
que lui et a 18 ans lorsqu'il sort du
service militaire il n'a qu'une seule
idée faire de l'argent et vite
il changea plusieurs reprises de travail
vit au dessus de ses moyens grosses
voitures club hippique costumes cher
dette crédit encore des dettes et trois
chèques sans provision tribunal prison à
la sortie le même manège reprend mais la
roue tourne encore plus vite là il ya un
accident de voiture un choc nerveux
plusieurs consultations chez un
psychiatre qui trouve un garçon
velléitaire une déprime de non réussite
c'était l'année dernière
patrick avait 22 ans à bosse en cours le
village où habitent ses parents ont dit
alors que le playboy blond est
maintenant prête à tout pour du fric
voilà ce soir ce que nous le portrait
que nous pouvons faire à partir des
seuls éléments dont nous disposons et
bien entendu au cours de l'instruction
la personnalité de l'assassin se
précisera mais je conçois que ce ne soit
pas le plus important
les obsèques du petit philippe bertrand
à 3 cet après midi pour la première fois
depuis trois jours on a un peu oublié
l'enquète et l'inculpé même si l'on a
appris que le bâtonnier de chaumont et
puis peut-être mettre polak avait décidé
de défendre pour ne plus penser qu'à la
tristesse des parents et des amis au
moment des obsèques du jeune philippe
près de 2000 personnes sont venues
rendre un dernier hommage à la petite
victime devant l'église saint bruno à 3
plusieurs centaines de gerbe et beaucoup
de larmes et puis ce fût le cimetière à
la fin d'une journée qui ressemblait
fort un jour de toussaint
une petite pluie fine s'est mise à
tomber lorsque les parents de philippe
bertrand ont accompagné le cercueil dans
le cimetière de pont sainte marie
[Musique]
madame bertrand en larmes et soutenue
par son mari et son père il n'y avait
plus que les parents dans le cimetière à
ce moment pour le dernier adieu est là
messieurs bonsoir vous avez vu ces
visages cette émotion et plus
profondément enfouis ce durcissement de
la colère une ville entière qui pendant
trois semaines a fait corps avec la
douleur des parents du petit philippe
bertrand
alors vous imaginez que dans cette
ambiance la justice et du mal à trouver
un peu de sérénité et la justice c'est
d'abord un jury qui a le droit de vie et
de mort un jury c'est de dire des hommes
ou des femmes que l'on choisira à trois
puisque normalement c'est aux assises de
l'eau que doit se dérouler le procès à
moins que la cour de cassation en décide
autrement
ce qui serait peut-être une bonne chose
la justice et aussi la défense patrick
henry l'assassin avait désigné un avocat
le bâtonnier bret maire mais le
bâtonnier a refusé compte tenu du climat
qui pèsent sur la ville tous les troyens
comprennent pourquoi j'ai refusé c'est
un drame bouleversant la mort d'un petit
enfant de 8 ans je suis moi même père et
grand-père de d'enfants qui ont le même
âge le petit fils alors voyez vous en
mon âme et conscience je pense que je
n'aurai pas une indépendance suffisante
d'esprit ni même une liberté totale et
que je ne pourrais pas défendre patrick
henry avec toute l'efficacité la
sérénité
un avocat on va dire que vous refusez de
défendre quelqu'un qui a commis un acte
que vous même vous réprouvé bien sûr je
leur ai pauvres citoyens temps comme le
grand père mais vous êtes quand même un
serviteur l'appareil judiciaire est ce
que vous avez l'impression d'adopter une
attitude sereine dans cette affaire oui
oui oui car je vous dise mais personnel
c'est je ne pense pas pouvoir le
défendre avec eux cette sérénité
justement cette efficacité que tout
avocat de tabarre à l'égard de de son
client
chacun l'a encore appréciera en son âme
et conscience
patrick henry sera quand même défendu
par un avocat de chaumont m bocquillon
et peut-être par un avocat de paris
métropole ac
le meurtre du petit philippe bertrand
patrick henry l'assassin devait
reconstituer le drame ce matin dans la
petite chambre d'un modeste hôtel de la
rue fortier à 3 un important dispositif
policier avait été mis en place pour
éviter tout incident de cette
reconstitution les enquêteurs espéraient
beaucoup et notamment la réponse à la
question
patrick henry at il tué le jeune
philippe bertrand avec préméditation ou
dans un instant de panique mais jean
pire à bout cette reconstitution a été
finalement décevante pour les enquêteurs
en raison de l'attitude du meurtrier
patrick henry avait peur de la foule
mais ce matin les habitants de trois ne
se sont même pas dérangés
la reconstitution a duré à peine trois
quarts d'heure patrick henry que vous
voyez sur ces images sortant
précipitamment de la brasserie des
charmilles a refusé de refaire le geste
meurtrier sur le mannequin que lui
présentait les enquêteurs il n'a pas
voulu non plus répondre aux questions
que lui posaient le juge d'instruction
mademoiselle gérard dans cette chambre
où depuis son horrible crime
tout est resté en place comme figé dans
l'horreur patrick henry à un mouvement
de recul face à l'entrée de la chambre
l'angle droit dans lequel les policiers
ont retrouvé le corps de l'enfant près
de la porte
le poste de télévision avec lequel il
tente avola six mois de distraire
philippe au cours de la reconstitution
patrick henry évite de s'approcher des
meubles de manipuler les quelques objets
traînant dans la chambre la cuisine à
plusieurs reprises les magistrats les
policiers répètent leurs ordres patrick
henry prostré semble ne rien entendre
les points importants que noël gérard
souhaitait vérifier n'ont pas pu être
vérifiées en partie ici sur le plan
matériel mais pas par les déclarations
de patrick henry qui a refusé de se
prêter à la reconstitution trop quel
état est et ils passeront pas vous dire
grand chose mais mal il a très mal
supporté
aujourd'hui non pas la reconstitution
puisqu'il n'ya pas une reconstitution
entreprenant parler mais la simple
évocation des faits qui sont déroulés
précisément dans la pièce où tout ça
vient de se faire ils seront quand même
est-ce que son émotion quand même à
percer parce que c'est quand même
robinho est ce qu'on est évidente
il était manifestement bouleverser cette
reconstitution aura apporté aucune
réponse sur trois points qui demeurent
mystérieux patrick henry avait il un
complice at il donné à l'enfant dès
samedi
faire et surtout question essentielle
at-il prémédité ce crime à soutenir
patrick henry philippe bertrand
patrick henry le détenu le plus détesté
de france philippe bertrand le petit
garçon pour lequel chacun de nous a le
plus espéré pleurait ce procès 3 va
s'ouvrir mardi et il doit durer jusqu'à
la fin de la semaine c'est un procès que
nous essaierons avec paul lefèvre de
vous commenter avec le maximum de recul
et c'est un procès douloureux
c'est un procès que les troyens même
vont s'efforcer de regarder de suivre
avec le minimum de passion et ce sera
difficile
pourtant là bas où le verrai tout au
long de l'enquêté réalisée par claude
sérillon et simon dre là-bas peu à peu
la tristesse l'un portait sur la colère
derrière ce mur de la prison de chaumont
à l'écart des autres détenus dans une
cellule surveillé jour et nuit depuis le
17 février 1976 patrick henry un homme
jeune à peine 24 ans au physique moyen
accusé d'enlèvement et de séquestration
d'enfants suivis de meurtre il encourt
la peine capitale
le vendredi 30 janvier peu après midi
les enfants de l'école saint pierre une
école du centre de trois sortent en
courant
le petit philippe bertrand sept ans à
quelques dizaines de mètres effectué à
pied pour retrouver son père patrick
henri laborde et l'enlève à ce moment
philippe bertrand le connaissait il
l'avait déjà vue chez ses parents puis
l'enfant est conduit dans cet hôtel des
charmilles et enfermé dans une chambre
au dessus de la salle du café
c'est là que philippe bertrand et tués
le lendemain après midi si l'on en croit
la version de son meurtrier trois
semaines plus tard patrick henry est
arrêté moins d'un an après il est jugé
face au magasin d'assurance du père de
sa victime
je crois beaucoup à la justice populaire
et la justice populaire
elle a toujours été très fidèle à sa
mission par conséquent il n'y a pas de
raison qu à trois il en soit
différemment
même si il ya un état d'esprit même s'il
ya une ambiance défavorable
lorsque à jury
gravi les marches qui l'amène à siéger
dans une enceinte de justice
il prend tout de suite et il acquiert
tout de suite eu la petite complètement
différente de celle qu'ils pouvaient
avoir précédemment
c'est à cela que je peux je croire leur
faire confiance vous ne craignez pas la
vengeance il peut tu avoir un esprit de
vengeance mais vous savez garder
vengeance qui s'explique
de toute façon j'espère plus que je ne
le crois mais je lui souhaite ardemment
et je suis même convaincu qu'en
définitive nous et parviendront c'est à
cela que nous essaierons d'aboutir
nous essaierons de dire que en
définitive la franche ans n'a pas sa
place dans une enceinte de justice
ce n'est plus à trois la même à part en
colère on en parle moins mais ce n'est
pas l'oubli beaucoup dans la ville
ajoute qu'aucun juré d'assises n'osera
se prononcer contre la peine capitale
les troyens n'ont pas effacé de leurs
souvenirs ses obsèques du petit philippe
d'autres en sont encore aux drames qui
se déroula dans leur département de
l'aube à la centrale de clairvaux il ya
un peu plus de cinq ans et puis
l'habitant de troie peut toujours relire
les journaux ce n'est pas au hasard des
titres de la presse régionale ou
nationale qu'il y trouvera quelques
mesures quelques moues réfléchi le
ministre et maire de la ville comme
d'autres ministres ne réclame est il pas
déjà un châtiment définitif aujourd'hui
c'est vrai le ton est plus serein le
drame de la mort de philippe bertrand
est encore très présent dans le coeur de
tous les troyens comme d'ailleurs de
tous les français par leur attitude de
réserve je puis vous garantir qu'il sort
marquer l'importance qu'ils attachent à
préserver la sérénité de la justice
néanmoins je crois que par leur silence
ils marqueront leur deuil et le respect
qu'ils doivent eux à la souffrance de
cette famille éprouvée
soixante quinze mille habitants dont un
quart de jeunes scolarisés des emplois
féminins dans la bonneterie qui n'est
plus ce qu'elle était une grande
bourgeoisie et une majorité de ruraux
partageant leurs voix politiques
équitablement à droite et à gauche
et puis une image de français moyens
aimant le bon ordre peu disert c'est en
raccourci cette ville bouleversé il ya
moins d'un an par la mort d'un enfant
les troyens ont ressenti au plus profond
d'eux mêmes la douleur de cette affaire
et ils ont partagé vraiment la peine des
parents ambulance antilles au profond
d'eux mêmes c'est certain ce qui m'a
choqué profondément points seulement en
journalisme en tant qu troyen c'est la
peinture c'est l'image qu'on veut donner
notre ville à lire certains confrères
parisiens on a l'impression qu'ici c'est
c'est la jungle c'est le far west
c'est profondément ridicule 3 c'est une
ville comme une autre avec sans doute
des excités mais il pas plus à 3
qu'ailleurs je ne vois pas en quoi on
puisse faire de notre ville
la peinture d'une ville sanguinaire nous
ne sommes pas des buveurs de sang jugé
la sphère patrick henry à 3 à perpignan
à strasbourg à brestois groupe je crois
que ça doit être pareil
voilà donc trois vieilles cités de
province industrieuse avec ses maisons
pour cartes postales nous n'y avons pas
trouvé les manifestations de haine
annoncé au certes lorsque patrick henry
comparaîtra il y aura bien des cris dans
la foule anonyme des cris réclamant sa
mort mais le plus inquiétant au fond
pour l'idée de justice que chacun doit
avoir c'est l'impression que déjà le
verdict est rendu que le procès ne sert
plus à rien de me au tribunal de troyes
s'ouvrira le procès de patrick henry
présumé coupable de l'assassinât d'un
enfant qui l'aurait enlevée qui l'avait
enlevée pour de l'argent comme le
rappelle certains confrères aujourd'hui
il y a eu en 76 ans 75 aussi un certain
nombre de meurtres d'enfants abominable
allez savoir pourquoi ces affaires n'ont
pas fait grand bruit
le meurtre du petit philippe bertrand à
3 à polariser la colère et quelques
autres sentiment de l'opinion publique
son impuissance à comprendre comment un
homme banal a pu en arriver là est
immense elle dépasse toute logique
pourtant il faudrait que la sérénité
puisse s'établir dans ce tribunal de
province avant de juger il faut savoir
et surtout refusé de dire je ne veux pas
savoir jean pierre berthet suivra pour
nous ce procès
au delà ou à travers patrick henry c'est
d'abord le principe même du procès qui
est en accusation dans une partie non
négligeable de l'opinion publique
il y a ceux qui réclament l exécution de
patrick henry le jour même de son
arrestation pour ces gens là les
tribunaux ont parfois d indulgence
coupable et il faut s'en méfier à
l'opposé il ya ceux qui dénoncent
l'hypocrisie d'un procès dont le verdict
la peine capitale serait à l'avance une
quasi certitude
en voilà qui ne crois pas une minute à
l'indépendance de conscience des juges
professionnels et des jurés populaires
paradoxalement le crime de patrick henry
aura donc réuni deux familles de
citoyens qui n'ont rien en commun si ce
n'est une confusion dramatique vengeance
et justice pense-t-il
c'est pareil la vérité est tout autre le
besoin de vengeance doit s'arrêter là où
l'action de la justice commence patrick
henry appartient à la catégorie des
criminels les plus odieux c'est
indéniable enlèvement et meurtre d'un
enfant avec demande de rançon aux
malheureux parents contre cet
enchaînement de crime
le code pénal n'a pas prévu une mais
deux fois la peine de mort et pourtant
demain matin devant la cour d'assises de
l'aube
il va falloir repartir de zéro et tenir
compte de la psychologie du passé de
l'accusé au moins autant que des faits
qui lui sont reprochés ne plus être
obsédé par le cynisme de patrick henry
souhaitant publiquement on s'en souvient
avant son arrestation
la mort des ravisseurs d'enfant ou ne
plus être influencé par l'empressement
de trois ministres a réclamé le
châtiment suprême en écho à
l'indignation populaire
l'horreur du crime peut à la rigueur
excuser les excès de passion des
premiers jours mais demain il y a une
vertu qui doit être commune à ceux qui
accusent et à ceux qui défendent la
dignité
quelques témoins attentifs ce matin
sagement arrêté sur les trottoirs un peu
plus de curieux surtout des femmes cet
après midi le procès du meurtrier du
petit philippe avait cependant une
apparence impressionnantes comme une
manifestation où l'on regarde les
arrivants en donnant à chacun un nom une
identité
les parents les avocats et puis les
journalistes multiplier dix fois on se
reconnaît on se salue on se concerte
parfois jusqu'à l'indécence lignac des
parisiens jette une troyenne qui renonce
à forcer les barrages policiers pour
entrer au tribunal le procès ne sera
donc pas publics il faut montrer des
cartes et des priorités dans la salle
d'audience l'accusé entre vers 9h45 les
débats commencent dehors la foule
redouté à temps
une quinzaine de jeunes militants
viendront le midi expliqué que la peine
de mort ne sert à rien que la société
est responsable seront repoussées arrêté
par la police sur le trottoir en face du
palais de justice
quelques personnes commencent en criant
des discussions mais les 1 face aux
autres ne se convaincront pas et des
dizaines de troyens attendent encore
dans l'après-midi sensible au
déploiement de presser de police car ils
sont venus pour entrevoir celui que
certains appellent le monstre le procès
de patrick henry l'assassin présumé du
petit philippe bertrand s'est ouvert ce
matin dans le calme à 3 devant la cour
d'assises de l'aube
patrick henry est arrivé au palais de
justice dans un fourgon cellulaire une
heure avant l'ouverture de ce procès un
important service d'ordre est en place
dans tout le quartier où une quarantaine
de personnes seulement attendre on ne
sait quoi
à l'intérieur du palais le public n'est
composée que de 20 curieux la salle
étant presque entièrement occupée par la
presse jean-pierre à bout et jean pierre
berthet sont sur place pour tf1 appel au
calme et la sérénité ont été entendus ce
matin 3 n'a pas sombré dans les excès la
violence que l'on pouvait craindre
l'instant le plus émouvant est elle
arrivée à 8h45 de marie françoise
bertrand la mère du petit philippe que
vous voyez sur ces images accompagnées
par l'avocat de la famille m joannes en
étant suivi le général bertrand le père
de philippe au dernier moment et contre
l'avis de leurs proches
les parents de philippe ont tenu à
assister au procès quelques instants
plus tard les défenseurs de patrick
henry
tout d'abord m robert badinter suivi du
bâtonnier de chaumont m bocquillon
arrivent à leur tour à l'extérieur
derrière les grilles du palais de
justice une cinquantaine de troyens et
de troyenne assiste muet à l'ouverture
de ce procès
dès 8 heures les 27 jurés inscrit au
barreau de loeb et les témoins
commencent à se présenter
la salle d'audience très petit et
presque exclusivement réservé aux
journalistes français et étrangers qui
représentent plus de 80 journaux radios
et télévisions patrick henry l'accusé
est arrivé à 8h05 dans un fourgon
cellulaire escorté de voitures de police
et deux motards pour faire face à toute
éventualité un très important service
d'ordre
deux escadrons de gardes mobiles une
section de crs et 40 policiers
contrôlaient tout le quartier
à 9h40 patrick henry que vous apercevez
de dos
sur ces images entre dans la salle
d'audience pas besoin de metteur en
scène pour diriger les acteurs de cette
extraordinaire dramatique judiciaire
la haine le chagrin et la peur ont déjà
marqué les débats d'une gravité
exceptionnelle
les parents du petit garçon assassinés
se sont finalement décidés à venir
explications de m ambre leurs avocats
monsieur même bertrand ne crois pas aux
prétendus rep au repentir de patrick
henry et ils ont décidé de venir le lui
dire en face
alors ils écoutent l'acte d'accusation
le regard fixé sur l'accusé ils revivent
leur calvaire quand il est question de
petit cadavre enroulé dans une
couverture et dissimulé sous un lit
patrick henry écoute lui aussi les yeux
baissés
on a beau le regarder sous tous les
angles il n'a rien décidément en
apparence du truand du tueur habitué des
cours d'assises costume trois pièces
très strictes cheveux blonds roux bien
peignés allure propres est un jeune
homme bien comme il faut serait on tenté
de dire en le croisant dans la rue sans
savoir
cette impression de normalité se
confirme quand il répond avec précision
sans aucun effet particulier aux
questions du président sagols devant lui
son avocat maître robert badinter il ne
fait aucun mystère de l'orientation
qu'il entend donner à sa défense
s'adressant aux jurés il y a les faits
il y à la personnalité de patrick henry
mais il ya aussi la question de fond à
laquelle vous devrait répondre pour ou
contre la peine de mort seul
en définitive les neuf jurés sont
énigmatiques mais n'est ce pas la
fonction qu'ils exigent
on sait simplement qu'il y a trois
femmes sans profession un agriculteur un
mécanicien
un électricien un magasinier un
commerçant et un directeur d'école
cet après midi ce sont des témoins sur
la personnalité de patrick henry qui
vont continuer à déposer le vendeur
et pourtant il y à au moins une raison
d'étouffer sa propre passion ce soir
quoi qu'on puisse penser de ce verdict
c'est le respect que nous devons tous je
crois que je peux le dire aux douze
juges de la cour d'assises de l'aube
il aura fallu du courage pour choisir
entre deux décisions de justice celle
qui sans aucun doute pour eux était la
plus difficile
patrick henry n'aura pas la tête
tranchée il le doit pour beaucoup à la
plaidoirie d'un avocat maître badinter
qui a su donner cet après midi à son
combat contre la peine de mort une
dimension une force exceptionnelle
jamais je pense des jurés n'avaient été
à ce point prévenus de leurs
responsabilités
on peut dire que maître badinter les a
littéralement placée au pied de la
guillotine il a pris le risque de dire
tout haut ce que beaucoup pensaient ou
murmurait à tort ou à raison
patrick henry condamné à mort le
président de la république ne le
gracierait pas pour affirmer aux jurés
qu'ils n'avaient pas le droit de se
tromper
maître badinter a rappelé l'exécution de
christian ranucci il y a 6 mois et les
copains les commentaires qui l'avait
accompagné à l'époque pas de pitié pour
les meurtriers d'enfants à ces jurés qui
avaient donc selon l'avocat un droit de
vie ou de mort un droit absolu sur
patrick henry l'alleud il fallait aussi
donner c'est ce qu'a fait maître
badinter des arguments contre la peine
capitale
et il y en as me semble-t-il qui a
particulièrement porté
faut-il exécuter cet homme pour
l'exemple
la ville de troyes est un test éloquent
mais tragique a fait remarquer maître
badinter en 72 quand buffet bontems
furent condamnés à mort dans ce même
palais de justice où était patrick henry
il était ici même à 3 et puis les jurés
ont vu le monstre laissé tomber son
masque de froideur à l'ultime minute de
son procès des sanglots dans la voix
patrick henry a dit ce que j'ai fait est
affreux je le regrette du fond du coeur
est depuis longtemps j'ai envie de
demander pardon aux parents de philippe
ultime comédie pour at on pensé mais
après le verdict quand le président des
assises le président sagols a expliqué
que la cour avait tenu compte de son
jeune âge
patrick henry a aussitôt répondu d'une
voix très ferme vous n'aurez pas à le
regretter je dois dire que cet instant
tout le monde a eu envie de le croire
cela dit ce soir au delà de patrick
henry il ya évidemment une question
qu'il faut se poser est ce
l'abolition de fait de la peine de mort
en france ce verdict
cet égard et il historique réponse de
maître badinter au micro de jean-pierre
à bout au moment dans l'histoire
judiciaire
et c'est sûrement moment important dans
la lutte contre la peine de mort mais je
ne crois pas qu'il faille dire que la
peine de mort est abolie
parce que patrick henry n'a pas été
condamné à mort vous êtes en présence
d'une décision mais la tête de mort est
toujours là
burri est censé représenter l'opinion
publique or l'opinion publique française
dans certains sondages semble se
manifester pour la peine de mort alors
que là les jurés ont pris une décision
différente ce project un grand pas dans
l'opinion publique non c'est une
situation tout à fait différente se
prononcer à propos du problème de la
peine de mort en août dans l'abstrait
c'est je dirais qu'au mode vient le
moment de la réalité vous devez vous
jurer décidé vous allez tuer quelqu'un
qui est devant vous et ce n'est plus une
question abstraite et je crois que c'est
là où on perçoit le mieux le problème
fondamental que pose la peine de mort
cette idée que on peut tuer quelqu'un
aussi criminel soit il a une société
comme la nôtre il est tellement
important aujourd'hui d'affirmer même si
c'est très difficile
quelques valeurs sacrées et la vie
c'est la valeur sacrée par définition
alors le crime à juste titre fait
horreur et la lutte contre le crime doit
être entreprise mais entreprise de telle
manière qu'elles respectent ce qui est
sacré celui qui alors là ne peut pas
être abolie par la justice par la
société
patrick henry alors célèbre patrick
harris est peut-être plus connus tout
parce qu'il a tué un enfant et deux pays
qui la tue un enfant il y en a eu
d'autres enfants qui ont ils sont morts
assassinés violée c'est absolument
incroyable ce qu'on peut lire dans les
journaux mais mais là patrick henry
c'est vrai que lui il n'a pas oublié
même les gens de la prison nous ne
savons savent qu'il est à chaque fois
qu'il ya un crime d'enfants on désigne
patrick henry à l'intérieur de la
détention
et ce jour là patrick henry ne peut
quasiment pas sortir de sa cellule et il
ne se montre pas il est immédiatement
submergé agressé et lui il tient par les
études par les études et par
l'abstraction par les mathématiques
c'était ça qui est intéressant dans son
cas c'est qu'il avait été victime de
l'émotion et que même douze années après
ils n'arrivaient pas à réellement
approché tout ce qui pouvait être la
matière humaine
tout ça c'était c'était trop sensible et
trop bouleversant pour lui donc il s'est
construit sur les mathématiques
l'informatique sur le chiffre de calcul
et il se crée une véritable les
véritables carapace une véritable
solidité et en plus ça vous dit qu'il a
il a demandé son transfert d'une
centrale dans une autre ou là où il
était moins bien
enfin la cellule était moins bien les
simplement parce qu'il aurait un
ordinateur voilà il a un ordinateur et
la possibilité de suivre des cours
d'informatique donc il est à une
cisaille mme qui est une prison
absolument atroce vraiment complètement
délabré et il dit d'ailleurs que s'il
avait eu de la culture il aurait
simplement pas commis ce crime
maintenant il va à la messe mais aussi
et là tous les jours depuis qu'il est en
prison
chaque jour
ils prient et il n'a jamais raté une
messe depuis le début de sa détention
vous voulez dire des choses alors rien
du tout non il dit vous a déclaré ceci
un jour je sortirai il faudra que je
sois prêt je serai j'aurai une
quarantaine d'années ces jeunes j'aurais
un métier dans ma vie j'aurais fait une
grosse bêtise j'aurais payé
j'aurais bien le droit de redevenir un
citoyen anonyme penser qu'elle reviendra
citoyens anonymes
patrick écouter s'il sort dans dix ans
il ya droit
donc je dirais qu'il ya peut-être je ne
dis pas que maintenant c'est vrai que
c'est vrai que dans la région de troyes
c'est tellement vif se souvenir s'il est
il date d'hier complètement cessé les
enfants et est ce que ce qu'ils peuvent
nous écouter l'actuellement a je crois
qu'il ne rate pas cette émission là oui
parce que vous auriez mise en sandwich
avec d'autres d'autres livres sur
d'autres thèmes
peut-être qui leur évitait mais je crois
que tous les livres ça veut dire toute
façon même bon 10 heures du soir ils
peuvent regarder la télévision
l'histoire étreint la france en cet
hiver 76 le rap plus le meurtre d'un
jeune garçon épouvante à temps l'auteur
fut cynique odieux les mots se sont
alors emballée
bonsoir la france a peur un enfant est
mort un 12 enfants au regard profond
assassiné étranglé ou étouffé on ne sait
pas encore le top 6 ne l'a pas
complètement révélé par le monstre qui
l'avait enlevée pour de l'argent patrick
henry est une relation de la famille il
fut interviewé à plusieurs reprises
avant son arrestation il n'était alors
que le suspect numéro un et les parents
viennent d'annoncer un appel au
ravisseur et veut dire qu avait quand
même beaucoup de coïncidences
reconnaissait le vous même qui faisait
quand même que vous auriez pu enfin vous
corresponde exactement oui bien sûr
bien sûr il ya eu des coïncidences qui
ont qui ont fait que d'ailleurs pose
c'est pourquoi la police s'est adressé à
moi c'est des coïncidences
puis il ajoute au micro d'une radio
votre avis le corps du petit garçon fut
découvert sous le lit de la chambre
d'hôtel que patrick henry avait loué
l'assassin est indéfendable
il encourt la peine de mort que 400
manifestants viennent réclamer à
l'ouverture du procès dans une
plaidoirie flamboyante robert badinter
son avocat arash patrick henry à la
guillotine
il est condamné à perpétuité en janvier
robert badinter devenu garde des sceaux
combat alors la peine de mort entre
autres à partir de l'exemple de patrick
henry
sachez bien que dans la foule qui a 3
crié au passage de bus fait de bons
temps au tour du palais de justice
amar préfère avoir longtemps se trouvait
un jeune homme qui s'appelait pas très
compris
croyez moi à ma stupéfaction quand je
l'aï appris j'ai compris ce que ce
jour-là pouvait signifier la valeur
dissuasif de la peine de mort
après 24 ans de cellules patrick henry
attendent derrière les murs de la prison
de caen aux yeux du ministère de la
justice
il présente aujourd'hui toutes les
garanties possibles d'une réinsertion
prisonnier modèle il a consacré sa
détention aux études un travail l'attend
à sa sortie qui pourrait intervenir
avant l'été
lionel pour patrick henry qui fut
condamné à la perpétuité en 1977 pour le
meurtre du petit philippe bertrand
la garde des sceaux a refusé de
commenter sa décision pour ne pas
participer à une médiatisation de la
faire dit-elle décisions démagogiques
selon le président de l'observatoire
international des prisons commentaires
thierry curtet patrick henry doit rester
en prison
c'était sa septième demande de remise en
liberté dans son communiqué la garde des
sceaux ne fournit pas d'explication sur
sa décision
il faut donc s'en tenir à quelques
lignes d'un communiqué la ministre de la
justice a procédé à un examen approfondi
du dossier
elle s'est entourée de nombreux avis
qu'elle a recueillis personnellement car
la décision lui incombe directement
l'émotion publique suscitées récemment
par cette nouvelle demande rendait le
dossier très politique
du côté de patrick henry on pensait
pourtant avoir rempli toutes les
conditions
je suis à la fois déçu et surpris déçu
parce que j'estimais c'est peut-être un
jugement personnel que patrick henry
remplissait toutes les conditions pour
pouvoir être libéré conditionnellement
ce qui n'est pas une mise en liberté
totale
très loin de là dans sa prison de caen
patrick henry a passé des diplômes
d'informatique notamment tous ses
proches l'estiment prêt à sortir après
24 années de détention dans l'émission
mots croisés sur france 2 le président
de l'association parents d'enfants
victimes faisait entendre une autre voix
je crois que entre le pardon et la
sanction sont des choses extrêmement
différentes
actuellement s'il était condamné je
pense qu'il aurait une peine de sûreté
de trente ans est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
attendre symboliquement cette date pour
penser à sa libération
à partir du 1er janvier 2001 les
demandes de remise en liberté deux
condamnés à perpétuité ne seront plus du
ressort du ministre mais d'une
commission indépendante
cinquième demande de mise en liberté
conditionnelle pour patrick henry
condamné en 1977 à perpétuité pour le
meurtre du petit philippe bertrand à
troyes dans l'aube
cette demande est examinée par une
nouvelle juridiction à caen reportage
patrick fourniol de leur décision dépend
la remise en liberté de patrick henry
ces magistrats s'apprêtait entendre
celui qui a déjà passé plus de 25 ans en
prison
près de la moitié de sa vie pour un
crime resté dans toutes les mémoires
la france a peur en cet hiver 76 la
france découvre celui que la presse
appelle le monstre l'homme qui a enlevé
sylvie étrangler un enfant de trois ans
patrick henry
nart les enquêteurs le cynisme et
l'arrogance de l'accusé glace un an plus
tard la cour d'assises de lot procès des
meurtriers mais surtout procès de la
peine de mort conduit par son avocat
robert badinter il lui évite la
guillotine malgré la fureur populaire
devenu prisonnier modèle patrick henry
demande cette fois sa libération cette
fois elle est refusée
jacques toubon puis elisabeth guigou
n'ont pas voulu prendre le risque
politique de libérer un assassin
d'enfants
mais depuis le 1er janvier tout a changé
ce n'est plus le garde des sceaux qui
décide mais une juridiction régionale
introduite par la nouvelle loi sur la
présomption d'innocence face à patrick
henry et son avocat un président deux
juges d'application des peines et le
procureur général une juridiction qui
laisse un peu d'espoir à la défense du
condamné
si cette libération intervenue elle
choque ram sauf l'argent c'est
inévitable mais ce choc aurait lieu même
dans 10 ans
le jugement a été mis en délibéré à 47
ans bardée de diplômes d'informaticiens
patrick henry veut recommencer une
nouvelle vie et se faire oublier
pour son avocat il n'est plus une menace
pour la société
la juridiction régionale de libération
conditionnelle réunis à caen dans le
calvados a donné un avis favorable à la
mise en liberté conditionnelle de
patrick henry
celui ci avait été condamné à la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité en
1977 pour le meurtre d'un enfant de 7
ans si cet avis est suivi patrick henry
pourrait être libérée dans
un délai de quatre semaines commentaires
yasmina ferveur avec florence bukiya ce
jour là c'est la huitième fois que
patrick henry fait une demande de remise
en liberté
mais c'est la première fois qu'elle est
examinée par des juges avant la loi de
janvier 2001 sur la présomption
d'innocence seuls les gardes des sceaux
avait le pouvoir d'accepter ces requêtes
pour les longues peines jacques toubon
et elisabeth guigou avait refusé la
liberté à patrick henry
un condamné à perpétuité sans doute trop
symbolique
la france a peu symbolique parce qu'en
ils enlèvent puis tu es un garçon de 7
ans suspecté par les enquêteurs il
nargue la police et les médias alors que
l'enfant est déjà mort symbolique parce
que robert badinter son avocat sauve la
tête de ce jeune homme de 23 ans alors
que l'opinion veut la mort aujourd'hui
la justice a pu examiner le dossier d'un
détenu modèle sans passion on sait que
le dossier patrick henry avait été
présenté au pays'' a plu j'ai remise
mais injustice
il était déjà bon mais
s'agissant d'une responsabilité
politique on a assisté de la part de ses
responsables à une sortie des dérobades
je suis satisfait de voir que les juges
se sont montrés plus qu elle représente
politique
les magistrats qui ont pris cette
décision souligne les modalités de cette
éventuelle mise en liberté
conditionnelle
il sera suivi pendant une période de
cette année il aura des donc des
contrôles à subir il devra répondre aux
convocations
on contrôlera son travail les mesures
habituelles d'assistance et de contrôle
si le parquet ne fait pas un ultime
appel patrick henry sera libre à 47 ans
il ya 23 ans il avait fait une promesse
aux jurys tués avait permis d'échapper à
la peine de mort
vous ne le regretterez pas
patrick henry est âgé aujourd'hui de 47
ans il a donc passé plus de la moitié de
sa vie en prison on pourrait même dire
qu'il a vécu deux vies celle du preneur
d'otages qui demandent une rançon après
avoir tué un enfant de sept ans après sa
condamnation en revanche et après avoir
échappé à la peine de mort
il a entamé une rédemption par les
études et il est devenu un prisonnier
exemplaires pierre nicolas
c'est à la sortie de cette école que
disparaît en janvier 1976 philippe
bertrand sept ans dans le pavillon de
ses parents quelques minutes plus tard
le téléphone sonne
l'enfant sera rendue contre une rançon
d'un million de francs après plusieurs
jours d'une enquête infructueuses la
famille lance un appel désespéré au
ravisseur les enquêteurs soupçonnent un
proche de la famille patrick henry un
jeune représentant de commerce endettés
qui nie être liés à l'enlèvement avec un
cynisme effroyable
bien sûr il ya eu des coïncidences qui
ont qui ont fait que d'ailleurs pour eux
c'est pourquoi la police s'est adressé à
moi c'est des coïncidences et quelle a
été votre sentiment
j'entendais ce capteur mais écoutez ça
fait plutôt ça fait mal au coeur pour
les parents puis surtout pour le petit
garçon est évidemment on souhaite un
dénouement très rapide et heureux de
cette affaire interviewé par une radio
patrick henry va même plus loin dans la
provocation enfants votre avis moi je
pense que c'est oui c'est mon avis la
question tourne ce pôle
[Applaudissements]
lepage pas sur patrick henry mentait
c'était bien lui qui avait enlevé puis
être anglais le petit philippe bertrand
il sera retrouvé sous un lit dans une
chambre d'hôtel sordides les premiers à
condamner l'assassin sont ses parents
nous personnellement on perd un garçon
de deux à trois jambes et des gens
perdent un peu plus de dix ans qui est
beaucoup plus terrible c'est alors que
même s'il était condamné à mort pour le
comprendre il
c'est normal moi j'estime que la
condamnation à mort est là juste
punition de ce qu'il a fait au moment du
procès la foule réclame la tête de celui
qui a dupé tout le monde mais un avocat
de grand talent robert badinter lui
évite la peine capitale condamné à
perpétuité patrick henry vient de passer
la moitié de sa vie en prison en juillet
dernier lisabeth guigou avait refusé la
libération conditionnelle de cet
assassin qui à lui seul poste depuis des
années cette question lancinante à tout
un pays
à partir de quand la dangerosité d'un
criminel est à l'effacer par une peine
d'emprisonnement
au point de le relâcher on se souvient
que pendant son procès en 1977 patrick
henry n'avait sauvé sa tête que grâce à
l'intervention de ses avocats dont
maître robert badinter il avait fait une
robert badinter de ce procès un vrai
plaidoyer contre la peine de mort et les
jurés l'avait suivie aujourd'hui encore
robert badinter interrogé par yasmina
farber se souvient j'ai appris sa
libération conditionnelle
je me suis souvenu de ses dernières
paroles à la cour d'assises
le président venait de lire la décision
des factions et l'émotion immense
tous croyaient ou presque ils seraient
condamnés à mort dans que fait qu'il
n'ait pas été suscité des mouvements
passionnés puis l'ordre serré tablier et
le président lui ai dit patrick henry
la cour a fait preuve votre égard d'une
grande mansuétude
souvenez vous en
et soyez en digne et patrick henry qui
il y avait beaucoup de mal à parler a
dit en réponse une voix blanche attend
encore
je remercie je n'aurai pas le regretter
et c'est cet engagement là je pense
qu'il a tenus au long du quart de siècle
écoulé et c'est ça qui a mené la
libération conditionnelle il a tenu sa
parole
patrick henry est sorti discrètement
hier soir de la maison d'arrêt de caen
après 25 ans d'incarcération il a
retrouvé un certain parfum de liberté
peu avant minuit accompagné par le
directeur de la prison personne ne
l'attendait vraiment à sa sortie mais
patrick henry savait qu'elle était
imminente
il y à une quinzaine de jours la
juridiction et régional de basse
normandie lui accorder enfin une
libération conditionnelle
c'était la huitième fois que patrick
henry la réclamait pour un de ses
anciens avocats
cette décision est juste si on ne fait
pas confiance à patrick ans il compte
tenu de kike preuve qu'il a donné de sa
volonté de se ré juste de se réadapter
de se sortir de de cette ambiance
criminels dans laquelle il avait vécu
6ans du peuple pas confiance on le froid
personnes cette libération marque un
nouvel acte de l'histoire de patrick
henry
en 1977 il était condamné à la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité pour
l'assassinât du petit philippe bertrand
après toutes ces années charles corlet
l'homme qui a décidé de lui tendre la
main en prison patrick henry travailler
pour lui ensemble ils ont décidé de
créer une société informatique
nous sommes dans l'ère du 21e siècle
je crois qu'il faut être loin du
lynchage du moyen-âge il faut essayer de
travailler dans notre siècle
malheureusement ceux qui crient le plus
fort c'est peut-être eu un jour qui
rompt un pour que roy problèmes avec
leurs enfants
et peut-être que dans dix ans dans 20
ans il trouve - charles corlet sur la
route
ries lui dire merci pourtant les mesures
de cette libération conditionnelle
impose certaines règles patrick henry
dormir à deux nuits par semaine en
prison et ce pendant huit mois il ne
pourra sortir du territoire français et
devra par ailleurs se soumettre à de
nombreux contrôles par un service de
probation pendant les sept prochaines
années
des règles décidées par le juge
d'application des peines qui peut au
premier faux pas le remettre en prison
patrie quand il le sait pour rester en
liberté il devra se faire discret et
surtout prouver qu'il est devenu un
homme fréquentable
[Musique]